This would be the answer for t. Fantastic work if you found it. We start by
multiplying both sides by the denominator, s plus t. This would give us 3s
squared plus 3st on the left and 4rt on the right. We just had to distribute
this 3s to each of these terms. Next we subtract 3st from both sides of the
equation. This allows us to get nothing but t terms on 1 side. Now that we have
terms of t on 1 side, and everything else on the other. We can factor a t out
from these terms. We'll have t times the quantity, 4r minus 3s. We divide both
sides of our equation by this quantity to get t alone. These reduce to 1,
leaving us with t equals this expression. I hope you're starting to see some
patterns when solving these equations.